>>> WE, THE NIGHTMAROF THIS
WAR HAS IMPACTED SO MANY PEOPLE
ALL AROUND THE WORLD, INCLUDING
AMERANS.
THERE'S PROOF OF THAAGAIN
TONIGHT.
JESSIE AND JACOB BACHMAN OF
ORANGE COUNTY, CALIFORNIA,
TRAVELLED TO KYIV LAST MONTH FOR
THE BIRTH OF THEIR DAUGHTER
THROUGH A SURROGATE.
THE PICTURES SHOW HOW THEY WERE
AND HOW IT SHOULD HAVE STAYED.
THEN ONLY TWO DAYS AFTER
VIVIAN'S BIRTH, JESSIE WOKE UP
TO THE SOUND OF SHELLING.
THE WAR HAD BEGUN.
THE COUPLE BEGAN ITS DANGEROUS
RALLY TO GET VIVIAN OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL AND OUT OF THE COUNTRY
SUDDENLY UNDER ATTACK.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE REVIEW AS A
DRIVER WHO ONLY SPOKE RUSSIAN
TRIED TO GET THEM OUT OF THE
CITY, DESTINED FOR THE TEMPORARY
EMBASSY IN LVIV.
THE MASSIVE GRIDLOCK TURNED THE
SIX-HOUR RIDE INTO 27 HOURS.
ONLY WHEN THEY WERE ON THE ROAD,
THEY LEARNED THE EMBASSY WAS
CLOSED.
SO THEY HEADED TO POLAND.
MASSIVE COMBAT VEHICLES ROLLED
PAST THEM.
THE FAMILY GOT WITHIN ABOUT
EIGHT MILES FROM THE POLISH
BORDER, THEY HAD NO IDEA HOW
MUCH LONGER THE FINAL LEG WOULD
SUDDENLY BECOME.
JACOB AND JESSIE BACHMAN JOIN ME
TONIGHT FROM CALIFORNIA ALONG
WITH VIVIAN.
IT IS SO GREAT TO MEET BOTH OF
YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, CONGRATULATIONS.
HOW ARE BOTH OF YOU AND YOUR
NEWBORN DAUGHTER DOING?
>> WE'RE DOING WELL.
THANK YOU.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
SO BEAUTIFUL.
ARE Y'ALL SLEEPING?
>> THANK YOU.
>> ARE YOU GETTING ANY SLEEP?
>> OH, A LITTLE.
WE'RE STILL JET LAGGED, SO WE'RE
TRYING THOUGH.
>> YEAH, LAST NIGHT WAS PROBABLY
THE FIRST NIGHT WE'VE GOTTEN
REALLY ANY SUBSTANTIAL SLEEP IN
THE PAST WEEK FOR NEWBORN
REASONS AND TRYING TO ESCAPE THE
COUNTRY.
>> SO, JACOB, CAN YOU JUST TAKE
US THROUGH HOW YOU END UP
GETTING TO THE POLISH BORDER?
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU REALIZED
YOU HAD TO GET TO THE BORDER?
I UNDERSTAND AT SOME POINT THE
CARS WERE SO BACKED UP.
AND THE LINE OF CARS AT THE
POLISH BORDER GOES ON FOR MILES
AND MILES AND MILES.
YOU HAD TO GET OUT AND WALK.
>> YES, YES.
WE WERE CONSTANTLY KEEPING UP
WITH OUR PROGRESS.
AFTER SLEEPING IN THE CAR
OVERNIGHT, WE WERE WITHIN -- WE
FELT LIKE ABOUT 20 KILOMETERS OF
THE BORDER.
AFTER THREE OR FOUR HOURS IN THE
CAR, WE FOUND OUT THAT WE
WERE -- WE HAD JUST VERY LITTLE.
SO, AT THAT POINT WE DECIDED
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE THE
WARMEST PART OF THE DAY AND THE
ONLY OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IT TO
THE BORDER BEFORE NIGHTFALL
WOULD BE TO GET OUT AND WALK.
OUR BIGGEST CONCERN WAS WITH OUR
DAUGHTER BEING FOUR DAYS OLD WAS
HYPOTHERMIA.
IT WAS REALLY COLD.
BUT WE FELT LIKE IF WE DIDN'T
ACT THEN, THEN WE WOULDN'T KNOW
HOW MUCH LONGER IT WOULD BE
UNTIL WE WOULD MAKE IT ACROSS.
>> AND JESSIE, THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF MOMS HAVING
TO DO, YOU KNOW, JUST MAKING
THAT WALK.
IT'S BEEN TERRIBLE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
BUT WITH A NEWBORN JUST FOUR
DAYS OLD, IT'S REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO HAVE HER
WITH YOU WALKING THROUGH
30-DEGREE WEATHER?
>> WELL, WHEN WE FIRST GOT OUT
OF THE CAR, I WAS WORRIED WE HAD
MADE THE WRONG DECISION.
IT WAS PRETTY WINDY OUTSIDE, AND
I'M SURE THE WIND CHILL WAS EVEN
COLDER THAN 30 DEGREES.
BUT WE CONSTANTLY STOPPED TO
MAKE SURE THE BABY WAS WARM
ENOUGH AND THAT SHE WAS
BREATHING.
AS THE WALK WENT ON, I REALIZED
WE MADE THE RIGHT DECISION.
WE JUST WALKED THROUGH MILES AND
MILES OF CARS THAT WEREN'T
MOVING AT ALL.
SO, I KNEW AT THAT POINT THAT
OUR WALK TO THE BORDER WAS THE
BEST DECISION WE MADE.
YOU KNOW, THE CRAZY THING IS WE
TALKED EIGHT MILES WITH A
NEWBORN, WHICH I THINK IS FAR.
BUT WHAT'S EVEN MORE, WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING NOW.
THEY'RE WALKING SO MUCH FURTHER
THAN THAT IN ORDER TO GET TO THE
BORDER.
SO, IT WAS BAD.
>> SOMETIMES PEOPLE SPEND DAYS
OUT THERE SLEEPING IN SCHOOL
HOUSES ALONG THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD.
JACOB, WE'VE GOT A VIDEO YOU
TOOK WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE WHEN
YOU FINALLY MADE IT TO THE
BORDER.
WHAT HAPPENED THEN?
>> ONCE WE GOT TO THE BORDER, WE
WERE OPTIMISTIC THAT THINGS WERE
GOING TO KIND OF GET BETTER.
WE HOPED WE WOULD FIND SOME
ORGANIZED WAY TO EXIT THE
COUNTRY, AND WE FOUND JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
WHAT WE FOUND WAS JUST THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, ALL
KIND OF PACKED ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER TRYING TO -- TRYING TO
EXIT THE COUNTRY.
WE WERE FORTUNATE THAT WE HAD A
FOUR-DAY-OLD INSTANT AND THAT
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE KIND OF
GIVEN A PREFERENTIAL SPOT IN
LINE.
SO, THAT ENABLED US TO BYPASS
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
BUT WE STILL AFTER THREE HOURS
OF WAITING, HAD STILL MADE VERY
LITTLE PROGRESS.
THAT'S WHEN THE CROWD KIND OF
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO --
THEY ASKED JESSE HOW OLD OUR
BABY WAS.
AND THEN I KIND OF PUSHED HER TO
THE FRONT OF THE LINE.
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
ACROSS.
>> I'M SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, I TRIED
TO CROSS WITH THEM BUT BECAUSE I
WAS A MALE, THE CROWD WOULDN'T
ALLOW ME TO CROSS.
SO, WE ENDED UP CROSSING --
CROSSED SEPARATELY, ME SEVERAL
HOURS LATER.
BUT -- AND ONLY WITH THE HELP OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS I
ACTUALLY ABLE TO CROSS BECAUSE
OF THE LIMITATIONS OF ALLOWING
MEN FROM LEAVING THE COUNTRY AT
THE TIME.
>> SO, WHAT IS IT LIKE -- I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE BIRTH OF A
CHILD IS SUCH AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIENCE THAT TO HAVE A STORY
LIKE THIS THAT YOU WILL TELL FOR
THE REST OF YOUR LIVES TO YOUR
DAUGHTER ABOUT HER AMAZING
JOURNEY, I MENTIONED JESSE, YOU
WERE IN UKRAINE, YOUR DAUGHTER
WAS BORN WITH THE HELP OF A
SURROGATE.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO CONTACT
THE SURROGATE?
DO YOU KNOW HOW SHE'S DOING?
>> WELL, OUR OLDEST DAUGHTER WAS
BORN VIA SURROGATE IN 2019.
SO, WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN IN
CONTACT BOTH OUR SURROGATE
MOTHERS.
THEY'RE BOTH EXPERIENCING SOME
HEAVY FIGHTING IN DIFFERENT
AREAS.
THEY DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF UKRAINE.
I REACHED OUT TO SURROGATE
TODAY, AND I'M KIND OF WORRIED
ABOUT HER BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
HEARD BACK FROM HER.
SHE'S BEEN CORRESPONDING THE
ENTIRE TIME UNTIL TODAY.
BUT AS OF YESTERDAY, SHE WAS
BACK IN HER HOMETOWN WITH HER
DAUGHTER.
>> WELL, SURROGATES ARE AN
EXTRAORDINARY -- TAKES AN
EXTRAORDINARY PERSON TO BE A
SURROGATE.
I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE KIDS WITH SURROGATES AS
WELL.
AND IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
BLESSING AND THEY'RE REALLY
REMARKABLE PEOPLE.
I HOPE THEY ARE WELL.
IT'S CERTAINLY A DIFFICU